2-2 AGAINST THE COYOTES.
HE WON NINE OF 11 GAMES THISDEN.
CAN THEY DO IT AGAIN HERE,
CHRISTIAN FISCHER ON THE OPENING
GOES THE COYOTES.
>> Matt: J.T. COMP FER HAS IT
BARRETT HAYTON.
>> M ZONE,WHAT AN OPPORTUNITY BY
MACKINNON.
HE SAW THREE OR FOUR IN THIS
GAME A THEY DID IN THE 3-1
WIN AGAINST VEGAS AS LAYER FOR
COLORADO WINS THIS DRAW.
THEY GO D to D.
LOOK AT ALL
DOUBT.
>> Matt: TOEWS GETTITI SHOT BYM.
COYOTES LOOK TO STRIP IT TOO MAY
COOKS IN THE KITCHEN?PUCK RIGHT.
>> Tyson: TEVO?
WE HAVEN'T HAD
DEFENSIVE ZONE UNTIL THEY GET TO
THIS LEVEL.
YOU FINE TUNE THAT GAME, TIE THS
RIGHT NOW.
HERE IS THE PLAY.38 SHOTS.
>> Matt: WOW.
BACK TO THE FRONTS.
TAKEN AWAY THE BOX.
>> Referee: 81, COLORADO, MINOR.
BACK OUT TIME TO
MAKE THIS STOP, WHICH HE DOES. .
WE TALK ABOUT MAKAR. SLUMP.
ONLY THERE. A
BEAUTIFUL PLAY.
OUT OF THE CORNER, HELM.
HELM TRYING TOHEY ARE ON THE IC,
THEY MAKE SOMETHING HAPPEN. OUT.
JAKOB CHYCHRUN.
KELLER..REHAND.
TAKES IT HYPE TO THE BACKHAND.
FISCHER.
HE PLAYED IN BEHIND THE NET.
DOWN LOW, AGAIN.
>>
COLORADO.
LET'S GO BACK TO THAT LAST
CHANCE. GOES.
MAYO.
CHECKED THAT TIME BY COLORADO.
IN TIGHT FOR KADRI. WAS TO ICIN.
HERE IS